hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to The Escapist
I still got a stuffy nose but I'm
feeling a lot better and I came up with
a big ol plan in my big brain of mine
such that I will be able to escape the
escapists once and for all
I said that I would and I know it's been
a while since I played it last and
unfortunately I have to start a new game
which is gonna means that I'm gonna have
to do this all again and you're gonna be
there derp derp goal slammed yeah it's
good enough you're gonna be smeared a
boo blue ball dumped ma'am basta or
ranae's burn hideo you're gonna be
taking three no taken three tram tram
lib tram lib front tram leblanc you're
gonna be Google you're gonna be aa
fierce and offer creme more mo offer
offer friend mo bigglesworth off man
pibbles
okay other didn't save a goddamn one of
those you King me God ah tinkle a Dingle
Dingle flap I didn't hit enter a goddamn
single time bum Li rim dou Flavell Dorf
lamech mokuba blasts am Baba Momo mom
blasts evimer bomb knob less amiable mom
flip Li fliblets lash clumb Rogo mogul
flow bambbles snatch officer off acronym
official mmm
boo official boo officer official boo /
bar barbar baboon new do grab grab grub
grub Lee rubley
oh okay finally we got dingle flap bum
leap rim no Flavell Dorf mokuba
blam of imam flee bleak Lum / rogue
ogumo go Ville grab babble snatch
officer off Akram ma'am
officer official boo officer bar bobbidi
boo offers a grub Lee you know who I'm
out of breath
so with this there's gonna be a lot of
stuff so I'm gonna get to the stuff
first and then get back to you in a
second
don't worry we got this okay so the
first thing you need to do okay
hey don't worry officer I'm not doing
anything just will you targeted room
mm-hmm
okay just say the first thing that you
do we oh hey how's it going oh you guys
are just so chipper and on point today
I'm so glad you need to start chipping
away at this wall so that when the night
comes you'll be able to get through here
and then replace it on the way out the
second thing you need to do is you need
to find clippers eventually to try to
cut your way through the fence outside
that's not say couldn't do without it
but it makes it awfully difficult if you
don't have it so you kind of need huh
sorry officer not doing anything what
are you doing warden Paul Soares junior
guards code what are you talking about
guards Code Red
were you dispensing on me huh not here
for calm mubaru
conversation I don't much care for this
prison I'm gonna get out of here you
screws I may have a stuffed up those
doesn't mean I'm gonna be slave to you
the other thing now I'm gonna need is
I'm gonna need to get some gosh darn
laundry done I'm gonna need to actually
do some gosh darn cleaning okay so I
need I need this uh
yeah the UH guard outfit okay this is a
tricky bit because I got to put on the
guard outfit to be able to get out the
door and then I got to immediately take
it off because if I don't I will I'll be
I'll have contraband then it won't be
good okay so I got that all right I'm
good I got my job quota i strewn plastic
knives all over the place but that's
okay because I don't care now I need to
go find me a file and eventually I could
chip through one of these walls and be
able to get to the stashes in there
there's probably something I just got
angry for a second there don't mind me
it's gonna keep chipping away at this
one because that's what I'm gonna be
able to work away on yeah man I'm all
out of Fork exercise period I love
exercise I can't wait to get my jams on
I love my chance o fight oh no babbles
man to mike rubra don't fight it's all
love and war okay well then that that
ended quickly let's keep give to myself
thank you wait what do we have last
shard plunger and pillow how would I
need but you're a month yeah I know you
didn't see nothing I you screw hey you
see you give me going in nobody is right
get right nope nope yeah oh
here the shower ah it feels so good how
you doing slab of dwarf I see you
scrubbing your slumber plump prim dough
row goguma gofal flim leak Lum
blam-blam-blam- on Mike rubra Dingle
flap bambbles snatch bubbly Oh No fight
I'll just pick up whatever scraps are
left
hey stop guarding his body like a bunch
of weird would you do into him what are
you doing - babbles ditch nothing imma
do wires necessary I think of our new
didn't see nothing what are you talking
about what are you doing you screw leave
me alone
hey damn and I need Intel beginning
gents ah what are you doing no no no ow
don't do it don't do it it's not okay
man no okay it's free time we do it's
free time it's free time a free man I'm
a free man hey I just wanted to study in
library there we go smart enough to make
a bad dummy good for me
all right there we go looks totally
normal natural and great my smart enough
yet I'm smart enough okay so I did all
right for the first night so long as I
don't lose everything all over again I
should be fine for the next day and then
I'm gonna find what I need now I'm gonna
escape out of here and hopefully they
stock up more Forks they didn't get
enough yes sir for Jeep I'm so chair oh
yeah succeed here I sleep with my eyes
open what's wrong with you ah ah fine I
hope someone does get knocked
unconscious oh no both of them that's so
sad for you okay don't help me at all
I'm on my way
fork fork fork fork fork I love my Forks
yes please I'm gonna I shut off your
screw I'm gonna store these in my dad
cuz I Vasily I'm gonna cut through that
wall and get to that stash behind the
wall because there might be a cutting
implement in there hi guys bro had to
Garbi leave me alone now I'm gonna be
able to do what I need to do on this
wall in my cell such that I can get
through here
possibly
I don't know if I quite have enough
chipping chipping chipping chipping I'm
gonna get through this wall
he gets walls gonna still hey hey that's
gone
you think this walls gonna get me I'm
just shouting them itself in my own cell
using this wall that I'm chipping down
who's gonna stop me huh oh I'm very
tired after all that week oh good thing
it's lunchtime that way I can recuperate
some health and I'll be a-ok for the
next task which is chopping down the
rest of them give me my food I'm just
gonna recuperate a little bit yeah
Lud this stuff is great I can't wait for
more my crib - MEMS match Babel Dorf go
go go go fool I know right I know
officer official boo Barba doo buh buh
buh buh buh buh get on with it I getting
on with it
I had enough food that's not for me a
laundry job damn it oh I can at least
fill my quota up stupid stupid stupid
okay time to ship more way Hey Oh what's
gonna do Hey oh who are you gonna know I
got this little more just a little more
just a little itty bitty more I do not
name hey officers how are you doing I'll
share one more chip they're gonna come
back this way are they here we go gotta
gotta gotta get a Gideon flimsy pickaxe
exactly what I needed
put it back put it back put it back yeah
no no no not like that put it back there
we go oh yeah baby I got a flimsy
pickaxe but that's exactly what I need
except for the fact that I need to cut
through things but hey I got some whoo I
so watch this watch - ladies and
gentlemen why'd you learn so this needs
a lot more chipping to go but if I did
one swing with this a bad boy Batman a
jammer
sad-looking like but um I mean ah no not
do nothing weird weird
weird exercise period I am feeling quite
exercised of Odysseus I'm gonna do just
that look at me go officer aren't you
proud of me tingle flap yes you roar
bambbles ness you better watch his back
bum Lee's looking out for me I always
like it when a bum legs on my back if
you know how to meet me
me okay so that's one chip away I need
to go evening meal I need to grab if
they have more knives they do not have
more knives I had if I had a shovel to I
could probably go out that way oh no oh
no poor bambbles Nance let me just see
if he's okay in his pockets yeah he's
all right worried what I need to do is I
need to put this away I do have a trowel
but I don't I don't want to risk digging
out just in case something goes terribly
wrong this is what I need to do this is
what I need to do because I need to
prepare I need to think ahead I need to
think like a genius that's that's what I
hey Hank
I'll get there yes sir absolutely I will
just just you wait this isn't suspicious
at all I'm just putting a bunch of
plastic knives
whatever whatever we're all right I
think actually I might be ready just
about ready to escape you but I'm not
quite so sure I wanna have some
guarantees and I'm gonna be able to get
out of here exactly what I needed
that's right I need food out there
that's right because it's gonna get very
exercise II when I'm doing my thing you
know when I'm squatting my thrusts and
cutting them
well I better move on what's evening
free time hey leave me alone screws yeah
these are contraband so I can't let
anyone know that I gots also I got a
sock mace but that's a whole nother
point yeah knowing Jenny
Chris
me knowin crush me just as a back-up
plan I'm gonna grab those spoons just in
case I I do have to like dig my way out
of here
because if I have to dig my way out of
here I need to make sure that I got
everything that I need did I do well
that's right I need oh I need hurry I
need to hurry quickly before I do this I
need that fork I need that forth for one
more thing cuz if I don't have that fork
ready I'm not gonna be able to break
that last block and I'm not gonna be
able to get out of here so I better make
sure that I actually have that cuz I
know what I need I definitely know I
guess I could miss evening roll call
it's just about nightfall if it's night
than the guys outside and the start
Portales won't shoot me in the face
that's exactly what I don't want I don't
want to be shot in the face
aren't you guys an evening roll call
what what the hell are you kidding me I
got shot cuz I was in the other
courtyard why why I wasn't even outside
I was in the other out what they just
shot me he just shot me for no reason he
took my guard outfit I'm a trowel what
the f this is such bull all right
whatever fine you know what I'm outta
here
these screws think they can hold me in
here they are wrong mister they are
wrong I'm the one they're trapped in
here with me there we
oh okay this is where things you oh hi
well alright then yeah nothing
suspicious what are you doing I don't
know if I have enough there goddammit I
don't even have a back-up plan now how
much is that doing okay it's doing
something that's all I can count for I
just gotta hope that I have enough of
something to be able to get it yeah no I
keep walking away yeah keep on walking
here hey
I gotta have enough I don't have enough
I am less screwed ah what are you doing
you know you're gonna you juking bastard
you think you can trick me huh I got
chocolate on my side and an iron will
I'm gonna do it good thing I count all
this chocolate hey yeah
no one can stop markiplier now no one
can prevent no no no my chocolate I'm a
chocolate are you bastard you rotten
bastard you took it why'd you take it oh
man you took my chocolate why did he
take my chocolate oh man it's gonna be
right down to the wire ain't it I just
need to get some more energy to Moore's
cuts you'll come on I just need to get
enough energy for one more cut give me
that stick deep breaths man exercise
your mind yeah yeah I'm so out of breath
from all that cutting yeah yeah but I
got enough there's enough left in me for
one more touch this is for the all the
butter biscuits in the world there's for
all the jump riders is for all the
chocolate bars Oh
yeah I did I escaped oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah oh yes I feel so good I finally did
it goddamn it I did it I did it
me I did it it feels good I tried real
hard oh man I had a plan and I did it I
did it everyone's so happy for me I've
been tazed Louisville oh yeah that's
great right
he took my chocolate but in the face of
adversity I had just enough to get out
of there oh yeah I'm celebrating too
much aren't I
hey I can take the celebration because
in the face of adversity and with the
hindrance of extreme stupidity I managed
to conquer all obstacles be able to
succeed when everyone thought that I
could probably succeed already and I
should have succeeded about 10 episodes
ago but hey all right now I did it it's
a little celebration time hey yeah okay
I'm done now
thank you everybody who gave me tips and
thank you everybody who established a
plan for me to get out of there
I really do appreciate it you guys I
needed your help because I had no idea
what I was gonna do that gunshot was
baloney then taking my chocolates was
just dirty but I beat it so thank you
all so much for watching I don't know if
I'm to play more of this I just wanted
to be able to beat one level but if I do
I will record it and let you know so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you think of my classic
escape in the comments below and as
always I will see you
next video by
he loved me twice as much as he ever
loved you his mother
mother shut up you know our mother only
complicated man